welcome to this video this is about day
three of the world rapid championships
in Dubai and I'm going to cover a couple
of games that were absolutely am a most
important for the forum for the final
result it's tricky to pick games because
they simply played so many games of this
huge field has some Carlton stated after
the tournament probably the strongest
Swiss tournament type of event in
history this is certainly true there
were gathered some amazing field um so
let's start and I'm going to state
something right away I also looked at an
accomplice games in the first two videos
he's a huge fan favorite and always yeah
to some interesting games I don't
feature one of his games in this video
it's simply that I want to concentrate
on the final result in a camera
unfortunately directly in round 11 the
first game that was played in this this
day 3 he lost his game against raja
baath in a complicated position he m he
made a big yea mistake or calculation
misstep and and after losing this game
he was basically out of it she was
simply too far behind to still get to
the absolute top bots for example he
didn't play Carson which is unfortunate
that those games are always very
interesting ok so we look at the round
11 game here between aronia and cars and
obviously very crucial match up and we
happen there are Gozen again the Rogozin
variation of the Queens gambit declined
the sort of Queens gambit nimmons oh
hybrid which is very popular nowadays
this line is not seen that often with
age six bishop f6 and Queen f6 but it is
serve a quite solid way to play
in fact something that I had looked at
and played myself a couple of years ago
when I looked at the Rogo's in what it
was not really that popular I also
studied exactly this line this line here
black gets the bishop pair both Bishop
f6 queena sexiest gained the bishops but
the disadvantages you're not very well
developed when I when I had studied this
I think I mostly looked at the Queen
Queen retreat to be aid the the problem
is white is very well developed and
black girl enjoys the bishops but the c8
bishops means not that great at the
moment it's a long term asset but the
tricky to activate a cover plate Queen
to f5 if this is a bit more more active
trying to get this night out of the
center this is what happened and now ed
form yeah why does got the IQ p but he's
got a huge edge and development so it's
certainly a position that Y term it's
not yeah afraid to play off shouldn't
shouldn't go for it it's just nice every
pieces every piece is in play it's still
however a fairly normal position Black
has not done anything wrong but we
rather quickly come to a critical
situation right here um yeah right here
it seems that black needs to be a yeah
somewhat modest in his in his play and
should set up something like let's say
Bishop c8 and Bishop to be eight just
withdraw those bishops maybe get the
Queen back to c7 at the right moment of
course it's trickier the ruckus on c3
opposed to the Queen but it seems that
what he played he played b5 Council
which is an attractive-looking move of
course you want to play actively but it
seems that this is not really that great
after that aronian seems to gain the
upper hand retreated to d3 yeah what
what about the capture this is the the
trick yeah bloggers using this
discovered attack and the back rank
weakness something like that it's very
ugly for white even Queen B 5 as
possible I wanted to go rook t1 can be
fat but creamy 5 is possible due to the
week back rank here black it's just just
better in this position so this is not
the way to go Bishop d3 is perfectly
fine and the whole thing here the whole
b5 business only really makes some sense
in connection with before and this is
what is played now the drawback of b5 in
general is this weakness of this
weaknesses on the C file especially c5
root can come here and night can come
here and one problem is once the night
moves um there are additional additional
issues we can now we can look at that
right now aronia plate looks c5 it seems
that Roxy for was a very good
alternative which is quickly given by by
a chess engine however this is one of
those lines that are very computer ish
and very difficult to tune yeah to
figure out for a human especially in
rapid play the ideas after be takes a
three which looks am I like the normal
move white has a very strong response
night c5 and this is setting up a double
threat 97 winning the exchange and
Queenie fall with mate on h7 and
attacking the loose bishop on f4 this is
also why instead of b5 probably one of
those retreats like bishop to be eight
was advisable this Bishop is somewhat
loose on on
for this position it seems is very good
for white but as mentioned it was it was
really tough to to figure out especially
considering that black also has a move
like a 2 which should be just answered
with the very cold-blooded rugae one and
nothing has changed basically Queenie
for is also interesting with Rukia
wonder some is also simply reply it
seems that this was a really good for
white but it wasn't played rooks e5 it
couldn't be 6 and g3 are pushing the
bishop back and went to be 8 yeah and
here there was a very interesting
possibility for white which I ever was
was rejected by her own young he played
Queen to e3 this move is understandable
if you are more understandable if you
see the alternative that also was very
interesting and this was route to h5 a
very aggressive move trying to go for a
king cytotec which does make some sense
why it has a huge concentration of
forces on the Kings side the nights here
and the bishop so it makes sense to go
for an attack on the king the idea of
luke h5 is in fact the very direct
Knight f6 check and then Queen III it is
very very dangerous if black plays
something like this yeah an
innocent-looking move then Knight f6 is
directly winning the game GF Queen III
and black can resign as Queen h6 and
mate is absolutely unavoidable it's
quite the remarkable how quickly this is
unfolding black he has busted he can he
cannot defend this in any way yeah
something like this it sir it's just a
medium
this means that black really must attend
to this threat Knight f6 one possibility
is rupee eight for example and then
Queen d2 or creed III is interesting
again threatening this and maybe 30 new
gauge six it leads to a very very
dangerous attack something like this is
some check given given by a bio dini
yeah very very tough to figure any of
this out something like this seems to be
the best line leading to an edge for
white but it's not very realistic to
calculate this in a rapid game it was
however an interesting alternative route
age five after and probably something
that leads to an edge by the way Queen
III the move aronian plate is not really
leading to anything but I really don't
want to be a any any more critical
because this is rapid chess and to look
at this with the computer and then point
out why this was wrong this was wrong
it's totally unrealistic it's simply not
possible to play a close to perfect
chess with very limited time in such
tactical positions f5f for this is the
counter play that Karl's needs here only
way to continue this our Quincy one back
Queen was attacked counter-attacking and
now like must retreat retreat his queen
rook c5 setting up the pin it seems that
this position while being super sharp
seems to be equal yeah after FTX g3 now
Aronian played the very principle in
strong move Knight to e5 yeah and it
came to this air now we have a huge
pinning situation 16 but it all seems to
be okay for black really it it holds
played queen to d6 and white now took
here yeah of course what cannot take
with the nine lesser check
checkmate quit made coming so only can
take with the rook takes Queen takes and
here we have a very very critical
situation cause the first took here here
in fact Queenie for was quite good but
ok cannot look at at all lines we could
be recaptured yeah and it seems that
right here Calvin commits a mistake and
this is rook f4 it's of course very
tough to play this position it's pure
tactics and you can easily stumble which
is happening here with Rugare form it
seems that Queenie 7 was a was somewhat
better but let's look what happened here
the problem is to reply Bishop to c4 JH
covers deform and the taxi 6 and black
really does not have any great answer to
that he played now g5 which loses but
Queen takes c6 96 is nothing that looks
particularly attractive it probably
needed to be done simply nothing else
but if you this is very typical you
calculate this and see okay well this is
terrible for me and I should do
something else and then you decide on
the other move or ever this is not
directly lost the other thing is losing
directly but one needs to admit in a
favor here very more complicated way
aronian took mrs. which is right King to
g7 and now the strong rook to be one
introducing the rook b7 idea this is
really the best play rook takes here
chechik and black must advance cannot go
back yeah it here very very wild
position of course and very very a
difficult to play I am unfortunately
don't don't know the the clock times so
hard to tell how much time aronian has
had left here every piece is hanging
basically and yeah well it's no surprise
with the black king being on the
that there is some winning continuation
it is however not at all easy if we look
at what the computer points out for
example the absolutely strongest
continuation is Bishop to be three but
this is very very difficult to calculate
yeah it's a it's almost like a study
like mating problem it's Bishop b3 as
the it's the strongest smooth it's based
on the fact that while Queens Quincy 696
is winning adds even a an additional
fork here if black takes it with the
king there is the absolutely murderous
move Queen c3 setting up a pin and now
threatening stuff like Queen III or
queen g3 especially our group b 5
there's a ton of threats here and it
seems that it's directly winning from
for white um yeah how realistic is it to
find that yeah I don't know very very
difficult there was some other good
lines bishop 83 it seems to win as well
yeah but it's a similar idea you give up
basically the cindy 5 not and now go for
mating attack here there are tricks like
Queen d5 rugby 5 in the mix okay Dwight
wins the Queen very difficult to to do
what Aronian played actually is a very
human decision he's spotted the move for
a queen a free check and he saw that
okay I have a draw right in the back I
cannot lose it because there are so many
checks with the King on the open bought
that there will always be a draw bar
perpetual check and maybe there is a win
it's a very very practical and
understandable decision at some only for
aronia in the set case that it is a draw
now black can take everything off here
even running to e5 with the King Jack
and now we can give up and must give up
the coup
and there is simply no win it's just
like that white has a ton of checks and
can even check all right get the Pawnee
rh6 but there is no wind available the
main problem being that you don't get
the night really into the tech you can
yeah you can give a check like like you
do ta get a check but the problem is if
you take here I think it didn't do this
all right you played the Queen check if
your if you take here then black is
getting this this counter-attack chat
and just um I think I'll laseema this is
more precise yeah and then it's it's a
perpetual check now given by black yeah
for aronian very unfortunate he had had
a really really good position and the
winning position technically but at the
end zone we came to this and here white
has no serious winning chance after this
Black is just holding this position
without any big effort so a draw in this
very crucial game where Carson was
somewhat lucky as he as he was lost but
it was a so complicated position that it
is very understandable that both sides
are made some mistake it's very very
understandable ok the next game I'm
going to look at is very important game
obviously and it's the matchup that is a
sort of appetizer for the World
Championship match to be held later it
seems in in sochi in russia between yeah
vishy anand as a challenge and an
Carlton so let's look at this game yeah
Carlson had white in this matchup and
was directly training him very a very
crucial game and council had the white
pieces I don't want to get I don't want
to look at the first couple of moves in
any detail it was really not much to
about we had a sloth and counted went
for the exchange variation align that
recently gained some popularity um I
think one reason is that the other lines
also don't give what much it's against
the Slav and here there have been some
recent developments to try to to push a
little mostly connected with the earlier
uxie one that could be three but and in
this game it's simply a case of I think
I'm Claire yeah wrong preparation I
don't know what happened here is that
right here White has gained upon but
Alan can play Quincy aid and here Midas
already worse I mean something must have
gone terribly wrong here in Carlin's
preparation maybe he um he just dumb
yeah I'm eat something you played
something wrong in terms of move order
it's it's already difficult here you
need to take b7 basically otherwise you
are simply worse with your poem on c3
maybe maybe the whole position it's not
I know what I can tell you is that there
is this variation there's this variation
without Luke see one rook c8 inserted
and this is very much equal and now we
have the same affair but with those
moves in and one problem is here if
white takes with the peace with what he
usually wants to do there is a six yeah
and well this is obviously not possible
without the rooks being played here can
white flat out flat out losers so you
need to get drop it back and then all
this is not really a great yeah black is
coming with coin a5 check and g5 and so
on it's just just not on so probably he
confused something and now was in this
in this really set position
yeah this is basically best play now we
have a total symmetry with black being
the more active more active site however
Carlton is a good defender we know that
and rather rather quickly it turned out
that there is not that much happening
this age 4g for business was a very good
idea getting counter play here against
blacks king or possibly go to the
seventh rank and we quickly can come to
this is this situation where a material
transformation is is now happening after
Bishop before black is threatening rook
see one checkmate so that after this
what is basically forced to player three
yeah and it seems that after after this
move it is equal but it's still tricky
and we see that in the game that both
sides can can easily easily stumble and
aren't here cap took on f3 with the
night which is yeah it's probably okay
there also was there also was the check
here first and then take headsets it's
comparable this thing check maybe this
was even better check well what he did
is okay it is only I mean it should lead
to a draw to put it put it on the table
straight away what I'm thinking it
should lead to a draw Jackie played a
look-see one maybe it was better to to
first take here it is as mentioned quite
quite dry very likely what will lose
further pawns especially the a porn
something like this here yeah like we'll
get the apron and then have a passer
here himself and in the game to look at
this we have a critical position here
I think here aland really should play
king of seven to get check his King into
play and then push the apron what he did
is he played the a pawn right away and
now King be one was played quite
surprising him um instead of King dear
one I thought that you can simply take
it here the idea is to put the night on
f4 and sacrifice your bishop for the
pawn this is I think a position where
only only white can be better but it
wasn't it wasn't played yeah if we look
at this for example a three and i'm
going to take it now White has this idea
to put pressure on d5 maybe win it and
we have a couple of points what can
never lose ever and what maybe you can
you can try to try to win this he played
kingdom one though approaching the
airport and after rugby to plate 96 yeah
and well you don't need to be a tactical
genius my 96 has a problem through crook
b6 was coming taking two pieces this
isn't the end of the world what white
can still relatively comfortably draw
this position but the weird thing is
probably Carlton has just over look to
the whole thing with rook b6 which seems
weird I know but he makes a really
substantial mistake now if you hear just
playing a king c2 yeah and ask black
okay you're going to take one of the
pieces then you still have a pretty easy
draw look c59 f-4s a very easy draw you
get the a pond simply not possible to to
keep and then you exchange all pawns and
can draw look against night it's very
easy yeah I can put it on the board if
it's false a bit too quick let's let say
this year I'm going here
take this point and then I'm going to
play you for later get rid of the last
porn I mean I don't really need to do
this but this is the least i can do i
can play you for exchange it and then
draw as a single night against the rook
after this if black plays a 3 you can
take with the bishop rook takes and then
just basically set up a fortress this is
also our waiter should be a bit more
precise I guess maybe here so that I
don't lose the Jeep on yeah this is
probably better so I can play a g5 and
possibly Bishop e7 f6 idea depends on
the on the concrete the concrete
position this still has very good to
drawing chances I mean it really should
draw I think it's us it's rookie it's
tricky but this is what you should have
tried it can still happen that you're
maybe zoosk want in the long run now
then I look of it that I look at it a
bit more a bit more carefully I had
looked at this line in my preparation
but it can happen that black can put it
here and advance the king and it can
happen that you that you lose the Jeep
on yeah it's not easy not easy at all
the thing is if we look at the game he
played this move after which a nun just
took it and now he played rugby 622
March the a pawn and here this is a very
simple win I mean like like very easy
what takes d5 ok but you just push the
apron and win the game very
straightforward yeah he had a somewhat
quick away but it was enough of black
it's just picking up check everything
here it keeps the porn so we can for the
sake of completeness
put this additional moves on the world
yeah like needs to get the king yep and
here it it was a it was accomplished
King bee three King do once the night so
very disappointing game for the world
champion and a bit weird he was probably
very irritated by the whole opening
business I know and then overlooked one
of those movie and maybe even rock b6 I
know it looks like very simple and he
shouldn't overlook it but you won't you
never know it's a it's very long event
and you're bound to have some some some
sort of blunder and in a game so I'm not
won this game certainly am important for
him even if it wasn't a particularly
great a brilliant game but important for
him to get a win against God's which has
been a while I mean considering all time
controls I read somewhere close to three
years that he beat him so very important
win and yeah it pretty much opened up
the whole tournament as some cons loss
led to a couple of players catching up
and in the next in the in the in the
penultimate round and round 14 there was
basically the deciding game of the whole
event let me load this all right it's
loaded counsel against greece shock I
agree shock a well-known strong rapid
intend blitz player and what not
especially betting classical time
controls bar but he's pretty much known
for his son yeah quick quick play and
turn and end and yeah and good flow of
playing with little time on the clock
let's see what happened um cal plays
defined we have a king's indian so a
very fighting opening
council place the same as she sometimes
does that it's not one of his main lines
maybe but he plays a wide range of
openings really however we quite quickly
come to a position well I'm not sure how
wide should play this a 66 setup is an
interesting way to play as black
especially if you don't want a long
theoretical discussion black intends to
it's possible to quickly intends to play
b5 here so if white plays a normal moves
now let's say queen here something then
be five is coming and you really want to
be a want to react to that if Black gets
time Mary might get some nice play on
the queenside this also is discouraging
long castling a bit him but b5 quickly
coming Carla plays the move c5 which
nowadays is probably the main
continuation here a move that has been
played a number of times by the biggest
expert off the unders a mesh which is
Alex Adria from Russia he's a fantastic
player if you want to study the zimage
just studied rare fees he really knows
what he's doing yes e5 has a good idea
to fix the beep on something like this
for example would be M from a strategic
point of view very very questionable as
black has those dark holds on the
queenside and no activity whatsoever
White has ideas very well not that this
someone suggested I need a new mouse I
guess it's a premier needs a new hand or
something the mouse is fine I don't know
this is the type of roots that whites
nights can can go to especially in an
endgame and does not look very good for
for black you want your pawns flexible
click be five which is a better choice
after which white took and played
neither for this is a as I have looked
up later totally normal continuation and
pretty much what I also have played in
games i guess and blitz
games the thing is however that
Carlton's next move it looks totally
normal but it seems to be a very serious
mistake he played Bishop to e2 a totally
normal looking move but it has a problem
it seems that Queen d2 is the better
choice here it should lead to position
yeah typically typically being a between
between equals slightly better for water
is pretty normal this position but
Bishop e2 let's look at the game maybe
you can figure out and take this as
small small puzzlers more exercise why
is this move questionable find the best
continuation from black I'll be silent
for a couple of seconds so that you have
the chance to pause the video yeah Black
has a very strong continuation and this
is B form before and you need to see the
second move after 9 a-4 now comes the
big point at night d5 and this is a
really ugly for white to meet ya lucky
uses this great situation on the e-file
you cannot take with the pawn ruby three
leads to a disastrously bad position for
white you have given up your your dark
squared bishop and you're going to fall
apart on the dark squares especially
considering how who I tonight's a
position this is flat-out losing provide
so we cannot take them yeah if you take
with the night you see that suddenly the
c6 pawn is transferred to d5 putting
pressure on e4 yeah and look at this
night very silly positioned black here
also is clearly better so cards was in
big trouble right out of the opening
here he must have confused something I
don't know he often gets in and slight
problems in the opening but this is
really substantial yeah he at the end
needed to play Bishop see one there is
nothing better and now we should rotated
to be 6
which was fine it's a good move he also
had the capture on f4 and d5 also an
interesting continuation directly
attacking e-form this however gives up
some control on the dark squares maybe
he didn't want to go for that it was
however interesting to play Knight b6
also was a good choice it's basically an
attacking d fire blankets threatening to
take on a phone on d4 so you probably
must do that and now has returned to e3
not good news after playing all this
back and forth bishop moves on d5 now
playback we shook again renewing this
this idea and note that a move like a
five looking totally normal this not
possible due to this technical trick and
black wins directly yeah so you cannot
advance that you cannot take it and it's
hanging just the very bad situation you
played Queen to d3 and now Grisha took
only formed a five was a very serious
alternative intending we should basics
maybe this was I was even the better
move it's difficult very attractive
position for black in any case and you
have many options that that make a good
impression yeah he took and played a
five no blacks idea now is to put the
center under fire why it still has a
very unstable central position and we
see that after these moves it seems by
the way that instead of root d 1e5 as
recommended by a by the engines is
better but it's a very very ugly move to
player you don't want to get into this
with tempo and I can very much
understand why cars didn't do it yeah in
any case we have a position where I'm
widest on the ropes it's a no matter how
you want to put it
the center is very vulnerable the dark
squares are vulnerable and black simply
has good pieces the next thing happening
is you get and direct attack on this and
just in addition there is no g-form yeah
it it gets dramatic now nigeria plate
and lagi form yeah like it's perfectly
placed yeah everything's nice
decentralized and the simple thread is
to take here and take on d4 yeah if I
from them was really no choice you need
to play this to cover d for at least for
the time being and the next move para
shock is very thematic played c5 very
strong move attacking White's weakness
and breaking up the scent and it leads
to also a liberation of the g7 bishop in
a way so that after this the bishop will
come out quickly and not look at this
little porn shaindy 45 yeah exchange
something here and now bishop take c-5m
and now we have this the threat also in
the game g3 it's it's really not
defensible anymore it took an hour King
takes yeah this looks very very ugly
King takes but what what else is there
the rook takes is too easy Queen Texas
the same thing and if you take with the
night sometime move like this is just
very strong it gets on the long diagonal
and why it really does not have a good
move here if we look at this for example
try to check trade we can just take here
at threaten Bishop g4 with the total
exchange into a king opponent game yeah
he took with the king maybe the the best
chance to confuse matters but
there is really not much to do jakiya
and Bishop deform plate now but we shall
it would have been interesting to learn
again what the time was him instead of
Bishop before there also was the move f5
and this seems to to win very
convincingly actually yeah the night is
attacked on its central opposed and it
really does not have anything great to
go to white can check try with with this
this type of stuff but check this is a
very simple winning check check check
and this is made next move yeah white
white can try this but here you can just
take check and black will win this with
with the pawn and the direct attack on
the king f5 was was it seems the
cleanest solution there is also after
this this additional idea king of eight
maybe even stronger so that after 96
Bishop takes there is no check available
f5 was was a pretty pretty direct win
the check however is not spoiling much
no f5 now he just delayed it for oneness
there also was a rookie five intending
group f5 it seems that this wins as well
a five-night f2 and takes here so I keep
it simple approach take the pawn and
keep all positional advantages intact
check check yeah why just trying to
escape with the king at least so that
you're not checkmated bishop to deform
Andrew k5 yeah and this is very very
crucial position father for the whole
for the whole event actually as here
Grisha kinda number of wins I mean f5
earlier was was easier to win it
probably the game would have not lasted
much longer then Griffith would have
taken the lead before the last round
yeah here King this rook sorry Queen the
Queen d7 was a strong move intending to
play a form on f4 directly it seems that
f4 directly is the most forceful one but
here we are already in the territory
where it is tricky for a human to figure
out the computers completely unfazed but
all of this and says minus 3 minus 4 but
still you need to play this it's not
easy at all especially check with the
blacks king also being slightly insecure
on the big problem here is that white
can never really take as this is check
check leading to disaster and when white
it's not able to take the question is
what are you actually playing the night
is hanging and after this black is
moving the porn forward but to me it is
not a very intuitive thing to play play
a 4 + f3 you want to get to the king
yeah this is a two twin but still you
need to do it and we shook didn't play
it he also there were more wins I mean
f4 was a when Queen d7 was a win I think
there were one or two more moves that
would have one instantly or not
instantly but yeah would have kept the
very big advantage and the probably
would have won he chose Queen to b6
which looks very normal
the rook and the text of the night it's
sort of a double attack but the bad
thing about the movies it's not winning
any more now White has Quincy form route
b5 and this seems to save the whole
thing very very close call but it seems
to be okay now for what materially
speaking it so it's okay anyway we are
on equal terms you have 3 / 4 points
each and what just about having the the
coordination that he needs there is no
mate the king is insecure but there is
no maid coming you tried it with g5 but
rock t5 is the saving move here getting
the rooks off and here it is not that
bad anymore the night on d3 is
protecting be too and the King on g2
later is pretty safe as the Queen on d5
covers the long diagonal here we are
already in the territory of being Adam
and in an equal position it should
should be a draw actually night before
it should be two and a form yeah white
has day upon but it does not look that
dangerous in any case f4 is a huge
account to play with the f porn all this
is perfectly ok and now agree shock
after some moves check check here
launched the h-bomb also the right
decision you want to use all your forces
um the thing is a five was played
and right now he am yeah he played a
very very risky move I guess just from a
strategic point of view a very risky
move and it makes life very difficult
for him I think if he just plays g4 here
they played a Troy yeah but if he plays
g4 he always has this counter player
deer on the light squares like this with
the drawn yeah let's say a six you go um
I can play Bishop sm but this is also
also possible with this this counter
counter play idea what can give some
checks but it is not leading to much now
let's say let's say check am it can even
just just retreat yeah the important
thing is that the pawns are on light
squares and we see the big difference in
the game he played h4 after which gods
and could play g4 and now the points you
are fixed on dark squares and can
actually protect by the night and the
problem is that a while h4 looks
aggressive and puts the poor near the
king the crucial squares like g3 are all
protected him and yeah the thing is this
position now yeah it's a very very
strong move for for Bishop to be played
yeah and the problem is it's it's close
to impossible to find it if you don't
have lots of time on your hands because
it's so counterintuitive and 22 actually
recognize why this is saving us
basically impossible um I can tell you
what you played he played Bishop to e3
and this is is losing the game in fact
it is losing no way no way back after
that um but yeah I don't know if you
have to treat this as an exercise and
possible to do I just show the move
Bishop c5 is the computer movement that
that keeps this this game going and yeah
who is going to find that it's just very
very strange move in a way okay there
are simple points about this if the
night takes check we're having a
perpetual check okay this is chef pretty
much understandable if the Queen takes
okay we also have a perpetual check so
it's clear that the captures are really
not the problem but why exactly is
Bishop c5 any better and then let's say
we should be three okay let's consider
what happened in the game we can look at
this briefly check he had this move was
played and King to do six and now Queen
d6 and we got into an end game where the
a porn at the end promoted so the Queen
trade here is the issue and if you now
look at the position after Bishop c5
Queen g7 yeah if I now go here I've got
Queen f5 actually oops check I probably
have to go here yeah I'm sorry I read
this wrong head to send my notes after
go here and now there's no Queen trade
with with Queen Queen d6 I mean Bishop
c5 really no one is going to find that
and this is the problem with it with h4
if you play G for you don't have those
problems the thing is also to see why
this H form configuration is such a
problem look at the game in the game
after this now the points are all fixed
here and white what's king is just
stopping the whole operation here on the
on the King side is just holding the
fort here while the night and pawn will
win the bishop look at this yeah
and white one this this Bishop here with
a pawn and here you're just holding the
King side if you compare this just for
argument's sake let's do it like this
with g4 if we we have the same thing
happening here let's say the check check
this check then black always has
discount to play with h4 um let me look
at this even aged 4 immediately nah
that's not necessary can you can just
just wait here and and be okay if white
now tries to promote you get rid of all
the pawns and this is what you cannot do
with the corner on g4 in the game like
this here you have no chance to trade
off this Jeep on to get rid of the last
point yeah so Carlton won this game at
the end a very M yeah lucky turn off
turn of Fortune yeah he was basically
busted right out of the opening and
Grisha kept multiple ways to to put him
away and at the end he he stumbled in a
position which really here let's say
about about here really should be a
should be drawn but it happens its rapid
chess and get this meant that Carlton
was going into the last round with a
with a lead of how the point and he had
the best of the best tiebreak which I
think was average rating something like
that and so what draw was enough which
she managed to get relatively easily
against a raja baath um so if you look
at those three games isolated here from
from cars you could get the impression
that it was a very lucky winner of this
tournament in a way it was lucky as you
have seen in the last game against grew
shocked if this would have one would
have been won by agree shock cars
probably wonder
the tournament but all in all it it was
a pretty deserved winner as he had some
excellent wins in the in the other games
yeah there this is not isolated to one
game this event or 22 games but to 2 215
yeah and he had won many games very
convincingly on the first two days he
had beaten for example kawana very
convincingly so it's really am it's
really been it has been a good event
form for Colin and that he actually
wanted was it had lucky because of this
final round game yeah and what else the
second place was taken by kawana and
third place by anand wishy actually the
only player of more than 100 contestants
without a defeat he also was some was
closed in one game he had a very bad
position against kawana which he which
he drew somehow so a very nice event and
if you are interested in watching video
footage of the event you can go to the
official site of this of this rapid and
Blitzer watch championship event it's
easiest is to go to go to the feed of
website feeder calm fi de calm and then
you find some banners leading to the to
the event and then they have video
coverage of the games mostly the top
board games and wii u can see the
players life I mean not live anymore
obviously it's a it's a it's a recorded
broadcast from from yesterday or the
days before what's so interesting to
watch them really playing the moves on
the board see the the facial expressions
and and emotions that are connected to
the game ok i hope you liked the
coverage of this rapid world
championships there's also the blitz
event um taking place right right after
I don't really want to cover blitz
seriously on a video maybe maybe if
there are some really great stuff
happening I will do one or two games but
the easiest for that is if you are
interested just watch the video is that
they have on the official site has
already pointed out you will see plenty
of games really played yeah on the
screen by the players and it's just
better to to look at them really playing
it out over the border just more fun to
watch all right i hope you enjoyed it
thanks for watching